오늘은 무기 선택 아이들. 많이들
궁금하실 거예요. 도대체 뭐가 좋냐?
별것도 아닌 거 같지만 상당히
복잡한이 메이플 플랜이 뭐가 좋냐.
자, 일단은 기준이 되는 캐릭터는
뭐냐? 일단 140레벨 기준으로
잡았고요. 여러분들이 좋아하시는
지오퍼 둘둘 근데 공용 부위는 이제
18% 낀 거 기준으로 매용 들어간
기준이고요. 그래서 한이 정도 되는
140레벨에 이제 정여축합 16에
매용 20에 그냥 15% 둘둘
기준으로 좀 잡았습니다. 자, 일단은
무기 옵션에 대해서 먼저 알아야 될게
있는데 무기 옵션이 우리가 이탈
옵션과 정 옵션이 있습니다. 첫 번째
줄에는 무조건 이탈 옵션만 뜨고요.
두 번째와 세 번째 줄에서도 이탈
옵션이 나오긴 해요. 근데이 수치를
보시면은 이탈 옵션이 보공이랑
공격력이랑 데미지는 1.5배 차이나
9%랑 6%, 9%랑 6%, 30%랑
20% 근데 이제 어 뭐야 이거 잘못
적었다.데 공격력은 첫 번째 줄은 정
옵션은 16 근데 두 세 번째 줄은
14 요렇게 나오죠. 그리고 크 같은
경우도 첫 번째 줄에서는 9%가
뜨는데 크학은 8%가 뜬다. 그니까
이게 공격력이랑 크악은 두 세 번째
줄에 떠도 상대적으로 나쁘지
않습니다. 자, 그리고 이제 보공이랑
데미지인데 자, 이거는 이제 봄매를
하시다 오신 분들은 이게 좀 적응이
안 되실 수 있겠지만 여기는 보공이랑
데미지를 뭐 유니온 이런 거
없습니다. 보조 이런 거 없다고.
그래서 보공이랑 데미지를 챙길 수
있는게 무기에 있는 잠재밖에 없어서이
보공과 데미지는 그냥 최종 데미지로
계산이 됩니다. 그리고 이제 보공과
데미지가 하변산이기 때문에 기본적으로
보공이 높아지면은 데미지의 효율은 좀
떨어지게 되겠죠. 자, 그리고 이제
공격력 퍼센트이 공격력 퍼센트 무게
붙는 거 있잖아.이 공격력 퍼센트는
어떻게 되냐? 장비 공격력에만 적용이
됩니다. 그래서 이게 뭐다? 지금은
무기랑 장갑. 그래서 여러분들 무기
공격력이 110에 장갑이 뭐
10이면은 10.98이 98이 오르는
겁니다. 09%는 여기서 이제 분노,
이유식, 알버프, 정축, 여, 표창
이런 건 다 안 들어가는 거예요.
자, 그리고 이제 크리티컬 패시브가
없는 직업은 크리티컬 옵션을 띄워도
아무런 효과가 없습니다. 왜? 우리는
기본적으로이 게임은 크리티컬 데미지가
0%입니다.이 패시브가 있어야
크리티컬 데미지가 생기는 거예요.
근데 이제 크리티컬 확률이 샤프가
들어가면은 우리가 크리티컬 데미지가
상승하기 때문에 그때는 이제 옵션이
효율이 생기는 거예요. 자, 그래
가지고 이제 직업별로 좀
살펴보겠습니다. 일단은 뭐 다들
아시겠지만 깡격력 그냥 좋아. 그리고
이제 공격력 9퍼는 여기서 이제
6.63이잖아요. 63이잖아요. 근데
만약 여러분들이 공격력을 이제 두
번째 줄이나 세 번째 줄에 이미
뽑았으면은 자 16에 대한 9퍼
14에 대한 9퍼 요게 이제
적용된다. 뭐 예를 들어 이런 건
이제 24잖아. 24면은 여기서 이제
공격력 9퍼가 한 공격력 2가 더
올라가는 거예요. 그래서 이제 두
번째 줄이랑 세 번째 줄에 공격력이
있을 때는 또 공포 효율이 또 어느
정도 나온다. 자, 그리고 이제 크는
이제 보마 기준으로 효율이 괜찮다.
나쁘지 않죠. 6%면. 그래서
공격력이 좋은데 깡공 세줄은 뭐다?
비싸. 비싸니까 추천하지 않습니다.
자, 그리고 이제 총 데미지. 총
데미지는 그냥 좋습니다. 깡이 지금
여기가 14잖아요. 니스록은 이제
14가 뜨잖아요. 근데 이게 깡공이
8%야. 근데 오히려 총 데미지가
효율이 훨씬 잘 나온다. 근데 인식은
지금 총 데미지가 별로 좋지가
않아요. 스공이 안 올라 가지고.
근데 일단 총 데미지가 사냥용으로는
좋습니다. 자, 그리고 두 번째
줄이랑 세 번째 줄은 6%로
뜨잖아요. 그래서 공격력 6%는 좀
맛이 없어요. 공격력은 웬만하면
9%로 떠야지 맛있다고. 근데 크학은
좀 괜찮죠. 크화학이 이제 8%랑
9% 차이라 두 번째 줄, 세 번째
줄의 뜨는 크화이 또 효율이
괜찮습니다. 그래서 어떤 매물이
좋다. 총 데미지랑 깡격이랑 크학
이렇게 붙은 매물이 가성비가 상당히
괜찮다는 거야. 그리고 공격력이
늘러날수록 효율이 감소하고 데미지도
늘어날수록 효율이 감소하고 크도
늘어날수록 감소하기 때문에 뭐다?
그냥 다 그냥 습. 데미지도 있고
공격력도 있고 크확도 그냥 한 주씩
뽑아 버려. 데미지 9% 공격력 12
크 8% 요런 거 이제 싸거든. 근데
이게 뭐다? 매물이 효율이 상당히
괜찮다는 거야. 자, 근데 이제 여긴
이제 보마 기준이고 신궁은 별로
크확이 안 좋습니다. 왜 그러냐?
옛는 기본적으로이 크리티컬 데미지
증가가 어떻게 적용이 되냐면
크리티컬이 떴을 때 스킬 데미지의
하변산이 되는 거예요. 그래서 예를
들어 이게 810이면은 크리가 뜬다고
1700% 막 이렇게 되는게
아니에요. 뭐 크뎀이 예를 들어 뭐
200%라고 하면은 그게 아니고
저기에 이제 크뎀이 합산으로 들어가서
세지는 겁니다. 그래 가지고 이제
샤프 받았을 때 850%가
1090%가 되는 거야. 그래 스나도
마찬가지야. 그래서 스나도 이게
3,000퍼잖아요. 3,000퍼인데
이게 샤프가 들어면 3,240%가
되는 거라 모다 신궁은 크학이
맛없다. 신궁은 크 쓰는 거
아닙니다. 자, 그다음에 이제
전사인데 전사도 뭐 똑같죠. 다른게
뭐다? 크학이 맛없다. 크학은 맛이
없어. 이게 전사도 이제 퍼뎀이 높고
크리티컬 데미지 패시브가 없기 때문에
그래서 뭐다? 공격력과 총 데미지
퍼센트가 섞인 매물을 뭐 최대한 잘
구해보자. 그리고 이제 첫 번째 줄은
대부분의 상황에서 총 데미지 9%
공격력 9% 매물이 까보다 저렴하기
때문에 적극 추천하다. 그니까
데미지가 짱이다. 아 저거 테스트는
저 올스탯이에요. 올스탯. 아 신경
안 써도 돼요. 저게 올스탯을
찍으면서 부스탯을 덜 찍었을 때
효율에 대해서 나타난 건데 신경 안
쓰셔도 됩니다. 자 그리고 이제
나로. 나로는 공격력이 기본적으로
낮기 때문에 표창을 더하더라도 공격력
효율이 모든 직업 중에 가장 좋은
직업이다. 자 근데 이제 또 반대로
뭐다? 공격력퍼는 효율이 상당히
구려. 공격력퍼가 지금 4.41이지.
전산 6.56인데 공격력 퍼가 나루는
원래도 공격력이 낮고 표창까지
들어가도 공격력이 낮은데 이게 표창이
안 들어간다고 공격력퍼가 그래서
나로는 무기 공격이 워낙 낮아서
공격력퍼가 굴립니다. 자 그리고
보마랑 마찬가지로 크학의 밸류가
나쁘지 않아 나쁘지 않다. 총
데미지는 뭐 여전히 좋다. 깡 효율이
정말 좋은 건 맞아. 집사가
9.79. 집이도 뭐 거의 뭐 8%
후반 때 나오겠죠. 그래서 좋은데
여전히 근데 나로도 총 데미지 효율이
좋아. 그래서 여러분들이 이제 나루
매물을 구할 때 총 데미지랑 크황
매물을 좀 구하면은 좀이 가성비적으로
좀 괜찮다. 총 데미지가 짱이야.
그니까 사냥용으로는. 자, 그리고
이제 보스무인데 결국에이 보공이
개사이다. 보공이 최종데미기 때문에
그냥 너무 좋아요. 그냥 압도해.
그러니까 여러분들이 보 00 공공 세
줄을 가져와도 보공 한 줄이
이깁니다. 보공이 다 이겨. 그냥
그래서 어줍지 않게 보공 띄워 가지고
사냥용, 보스용 이거 하이브리드로
써야지 이런 거 하지 마세요. 보공
60% 깡으로 된 것만 사도 별로 안
비싸잖아요. 보공 60% 막 엄청
비싼 건 아니거든요. 리버스 아니면
그냥 그런 거 끼는게 훨씬 셉니다.
무조건 그렇게 쓰세요. 근데 뭐
여러분들이 나는 그래도 두 개 절대
못 맞추겠다 하시면은 보공 30에 뭐
깡공깡 있는 거 써도 되는데 그나마
람피온은 좀 효율이 나오거든요. 근데
람피온도 50 몇 %밖에 안
나오거든. 그래서 추천을 하지
않습니다. 그리고 방문은 현재 효율이
안 나옵니다. 자, 그냥 보공
60%가 짱이다. 그냥 보공
30%플러스 뭐 뭔 지랄 연병을 해도
못 이겨요. 그냥 보공 60미만
잡이야. 자, 그럼 이제 우리가 보공
60을 직접 띄우면은 안 돼. 근데
그렇다고 기대값 2,000개 넘음.
큐브 2,000개 넘는다고. 그럼
뭐다? 놀리는 직보다는 보공
60플러스 알파 놀리는 보보 놀이는
보보공 보공 보뎀 이런 거 노린다고
돌리면서 그런 거 이제 돌리는
사람들이 부산물로 보공 60 나오면은
팔거든 그런 걸 사라는 거야 보스
무기로 이렇게 맞추시라는 겁니다. 자
그리고 법사인데 뭐 이거는 제가 안
하려 했는데 또 이제 물어보실테니까
사실 여기 메이플 플래닛이에 90%는
사이콜이잖아요. 그래서 법사를 제가
좀 깔끔하게 해 드리고 싶었는데 이게
좀 계속 오류가 나 가지고 그냥 제가
이제 이거 손으로 구한 거 예전에
구한 거거든요. 그냥 이거 참고만
하세요. 정확하지 않을 수 있어.
근데 얼추 맞긴 할 거야. 이거는
근데 170 기준이에요. 170
기준으로 좀 잡았고요. 이거는 좀
준지작 기준. 그냥 흐름만 따라가.
그 수치보다는 흐름만 따라가. 디테일
틀릴 수 있어.이 이게 제가 막 엄청
정확하게 계산했다고 못해서 근데 뭐
참고만 하세요. 자, 법사는
물리디어와 다르게 스펙이 높아질수록
오히려 스펙업 효율이 늘어난다. 자,
이게 왜 그러냐면은 물리딜러는 그냥
공격력이 100에서 110으로
늘어나면 그냥 10% 세집니다.
100에서 120으로 늘어나면 20%
세지고 그런 식으로 세져요. 근데
법사는 더 세져요. 왜 그러냐?
재산식을 보면 뭐 어쩌고 저쩌고 적혀
있는데 마력 제곱분의 1천이
있습니다. 마력 제곱분의 1천.
그래서 이것 때문에 그냥
1천000분의 마력 제곱. 이것
때문에 마력이 10%가 늘어난다고
내가 10%가 세지는게 아니야. 더
세져요. 고스팩에서 완전 낮을 때는
오히려 약한데 스펙이 올라갈수록 기아
급수적으로 세져요. 제곱이다 보니까.
자, 그리고 이제 또 아셔야 되는게
한마 개념. 한마 개념. 이거는
이렇게 하면 안 된는데. 내가 이전
영상에서도 드래곤 설명할 때도 했지만
방어구랑 장신구에 우리가 인트퍼가
겁나 붙어 있잖아요. 그 다 합치면
막 140% 150% 찍힌다고요.
시작까지 가면은 그럼 뭐야? 우리가
인트 1을 찍으면은 마력이 2.5가
오른다는 거예요. 그래 가지고 인트가
마력보다 효율이 거의 2.5배
2.7배 정도 줬습니다. 그리고 인트
퍼는 많잖아. 근데 마력 퍼는
무기에만 있다고. 그니까 인트폰 이미
내가 150%를 찍었는데 여기서
10%가 더 늘어봤자 10%가
세지는게 아니고 260분의 250만큼
세지니까 뭐 한 3점 몇 %만
세지잖아요. 마력퍼가 훨씬 효율이
좋다는 거다. 숨마력은 효율이 좋지
않다. 그러니까 이게 막 사람들이
다이몬 할 때 한마 몇이라고
하잖아요. 그러면 안 돼요. 마력
높고 인트 낮은 다이몬은 그냥 쓰레기
다이몬이에요. 같은 한 마여도. 근데
반대로 인트가 높고 마력이 낮은
다이몬은 똑같은 다이몬이어도 거의
마력이 10, 10몇 차이까지 날 수
있는 거죠. 자, 그래 가지고 스펙이
낮으면 마력퍼의 효율이 내려가기
때문에 총 데미지 플러스 마력퍼
매물의 효율이 좋다. 매물을 구할 때
너무 마력퍼에 집착하지 말고 이것도
똑같아. 그냥 오늘 그냥 총
데미지야. 오늘 기승전 그냥 총
데미지가 최고다. 그니까 근데 법사는
상대적으로 마력파가 너무 좋아 가지고
총 데미지율이 상대적으로 떨어지긴
하는데 그만큼 마력퍼 매물이 너무
비싸요. 그래서 총 데미지를 적당히
섞인 거를 살아. 자, 그리고 무기들
같은 경우는 이런게 이제 힘, 힘퍼,
깡임 효율이 안 나와요. 저
스펙에서도 2.54, 1.85 이렇게
나오잖아. 근데 이게 고스팩
기준에서도 인트퍼가 효율이 나쁘지
않아요. 깡인트도 마찬가지고. 그래
가지고 여러분들이 이제 뭐 마력에 뭐
인트 달려 있는 거, 마력 총됨
인트퍼 요런 거를 사시는 것도 효율이
나쁘지 않다는 겁니다. 그리고 이제
보스는 물리딜러와 다르게 보마를 사도
나쁘지 않습니다. 공격력은 효율이 저
스펙에서도 9%고스팩
찍으면은 뭐 6% 7% 이렇게 나오는
7% 막 이렇게까지 깎이거든요. 근데
마력은 오히려 엄청 높아져요. 막
15% 이렇게 나오잖아. 그래서
뭐다? 보마도 괜찮은 선택지다. 보스
무기를 낄 때. 그래서 요렇게 좀
정리해서 보겠습니다. 근데 뭐 그냥
보보 두 줄 끼는 것도 나쁘지 않은게
그냥 그게 더 싸요. 보마을 똑같이
이제 약간 하이브리드로 하려는
사람들이 보마를 사